[Music]
welcome to the eviction 2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon-fed wow
just don't lie to me don't call me alive
I'm not gonna lie down and take it
can I have a break
about the Coronation Street isn't it
you're evicted
[Music]
well firstly massive congratulations on
getting this far you are officially a
finalist in the eviction 2022 one of you
is going to be walking away completely
empty-handed and one of you is going to
be walking away with 20 000 pounds cash
prize no strings attached
you've demonstrated that you're great at
sales you can sell deals you can raise
Finance but I really now want to see the
nitty-gritty of how you're actually
going to run your own property business
so this challenge is going to be
preparing and putting together your
business plans
although you've grown a lot I think this
is really the most important challenge
because this is me seeing who deserves
us the most Who's got what it takes why
do you think you've made it this far
Adam what do you think I've kept you in
the eviction so far because each and
every time that I've been doing a
challenge I may not have gone into it
the strongest candidate but when I've
come out the other end of it I feel like
I've been a very strong candidate
shirelle why do you think that I've kept
you in so long my skills that I have
that they've been inside each challenge
they've kind of been unpeeled and
they've been able to kind of shine
through I've also been able to lead well
so I feel like that's kind of shine
through to help us hit certain successes
so we're going to be meeting back in
three days with your business plans
Russell who's the CEO of our development
company he's going to be looking at your
business plans feeding his thoughts back
to me also Evans who won last year
eviction 2021 he's also going to be
chatting with you feeding back to me and
as I said there's only going to be one
winner so go kick some ass I'm excited
to see your business plans and I'll see
you in three days time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
guys well we've been over your business
plans how did you get on with the
challenge Adam of putting your business
plan together
for me business plan is a it's a first
for me I've never done this before
with the brr strategy that I'm going to
do I've also got an exit strategy of
service accommodation so I was trying to
think you know how do I structure this
because there's two major parts to it
and obviously I want to do it on repeat
so I'm going to do it one property
pulling my money out and then exit with
service accommodation so it's just how
I'm going about structuring that so that
Samuel understands exactly how I'm going
to you know use the money
for me location wise where I would
invest I'm obviously very familiar with
reading and I know it's a very good area
especially for service accommodation but
the surrounding areas like Basingstoke
and even towards Oxford that was also
really good for sa but I could
potentially buy a lower and uplift the
value so what the strategy of pulling
the money out would work really well in
those areas
I feel really positive because when I've
got Italian bathroom fitting company
already
and I've got very close friends that are
in the trains as well I'll be able to
get a lot of my stuff at cost I'll be
able to do stuff without any profit
being added so I can do even labor at
costs
[Music]
I feel amazing I feel really good
what did you think of your business plan
Adam I was really pleased with it you
know what I thought of it yeah yes
please
I thought it was terrible oh okay
and so did Russell
[Music]
so I had a read through your business
plan didn't take me very long
[Music]
I'm a numbers guy so when I see a
business plan the first thing I always
flicked through is I want to see the
projections the numbers there's not
really any in your plan is there no I
didn't labor on the numbers too much no
it's a bit disappointing
the whole point of a business plan is to
go this is rejected figures what you
expect to need I don't know from this
what your actual plan is I mean
literally Capital requirements you've
put 20 round invested by the owner who
incidentally had the prize money plus
any extra needed using Standard Loans
it's like
any extra needed how much needed well I
haven't got a property you know secured
at the moment but I'm I'm sort of
guessing I may need to put another 20
grand of my own money you know in in as
well have you got that I'd be able to
get that yeah
here's your projections right
projections year one two projects
completed and up and running
year five ten projects completed and up
and running I don't even know what that
means what does what does that what does
that even mean so a brr through to
staged and a service accommodation ready
to rent okay so that's your our goal
from Year One so how much cash would you
need for that
that's the sort of stuff that should be
in here right year one eat 80 grand I'm
gonna go and buy a BRI unit
approximately these These are the
figures this is the sort of property I'm
looking for a 200 gram property that
needs a you know what I mean I've got no
idea because this to me this reads us
I'm just going to get much money off of
many people as I can
and buy properties
and rent them out of service
accommodation that's my plan
that's you know I mean that's not really
what I'm going with this is it not that
we're going to explain to me I don't
obviously don't understand the product
like that to me sounds exactly what the
plan is so where have I got you wrong
where have I misunderstood
well I mean I don't see a floor in that
I mean if I can use other people's money
to gain properties and you know build my
generation wealth through that I think
what's the issue with that sorry I don't
understand so it is the plan yeah yeah
especially just said it wasn't sorry I
feel like you're trying to treat me no
no I'm just asking you if that was that
was well I'm not saying it's a bad plan
I'm just asking if that was a plan but
that's all I can engage with it you said
it wasn't and they say it is
the point of a business plan is to get
someone to invest in your business right
if I was looking to invest in your
business I was at a bank
number one I'd be concerned that there
was Zero figures what exactly am I
investing in but number two the plans is
so heavily hinged on borrowing other
money that's all the plan is
I feel like my 20 Grands almost like a
drop in the ocean
I'd have it definitely have a think
about some projected numbers because
he's going to be asking you questions
about you know you've said oh yeah two
properties in year One what does that
actually look like sure because we don't
know even this it's mainly about the
profit from the service accommodation
what does it look like what how are we
going to pay back the investors none of
these figures are on paper sure I'm sure
the plan will work but I can't see that
from this does that make sense yeah
absolutely I seriously haven't think
about that when you go into your because
you're going to need to be prepared to
answer some difficult questions from
Samuel sure okay appreciate that thank
you Adam really appreciate it
[Music]
your year one projections it just says
two projects completed and set up and
running
what what are those projects so it would
be brr straight into sa so I'd
refurbished property refinance it and
then set it up as a service
accommodation and then this last page is
just talking about how great service
accommodation is
I mean where
where are the figures the details your
strategy what your returns are wanting
to be how much you're purchasing for
what your profit margins are where is
that I want to purchase property do it
up
to a very high standard I can do all of
the works myself if I can't I've got
very good a massive Power Team around me
I've Got Friends that I've got a great
friend who's a builder I've got a great
friend who's a roofer I can get the
costs really low so there's minimal risk
so I'd be able to draw out a good you
know even profit as well as your own
money here's the thing that the hardest
part about your business plan what
you've just said it's finding the deals
that's tough doesn't talk about that
does it in here at all the hardest bit
to grow in a portfolio of these top
Stills you're talking about buy
refurbish if I had to pull all your
money out the hardest bit is fine in the
deals is it on Market off Market there's
just nothing in building Rapport uh good
rapport with estate agents in the area
already that's not in here is it no it's
not fair the other hardest bit is
Raising Finance
um I've actually put this to my main
investor who's actually my
brother-in-law and this is a big passion
for me because I want to grow General
generational wealth for my family and he
is 100 on board so is that in here
no it's not there I wanted to shock you
with it I was trying to well this this
was what this was the challenge Adam it
was I just wanted to sort of come in
with extra bits you've not got about how
you're going to raise the finance about
how you're going to find the deals
basically the fundamental parts of what
you need to be able to do you should be
banging on about that in here sure sure
this is how I'm going to do it this is
the plan step by step this is why I'm
stronger than competitors this is what's
going to set me apart it's just not in
here it's just rubbish
I was a little bit surprised that in
your whole business plan even over like
years and years worth of building up
your business there's zero ownership
it's all about rent to rent I wasn't
surprised about that so for the first
year I'm looking at the service
accommodation brand recognition so if I
can have that with free firms it's like
constantly book with me I'll have like
10 service accommodation set up I'll be
positively um cash flowing 15K a month
and I'm gonna have an investor list of
50 vetted people you know so they're
good to go they've got money and they
actually want to get some deals I want
to create an investor community so all
my investors maybe we meet up twice a
year so others can meet each other and
then we're just like brainstorming just
keep everyone's Spirits high and I want
to be a paid keynote speaker and an
International Event and promoting my own
kind of um like self-development
training package that I can do as well
so the property side will be
facilitating me to do some of these
other things that I love
thank you for putting this together it's
got
some nice clear your projections numbers
however
I actually have read it twice now
and I actually don't totally understand
it
[Music]
so if honey bird's nests was making 182
000 pounds yep you've got your taxes
down at
5167. what about that so the vat I
haven't got that in there I noticed yeah
that will take 20 of this
20 of your turnover
because of my understanding this is why
I need to speak to accountant is that if
you are making money in a business but
you're investing it back into the
business you get taxed on lessons it's
really simple right you pay tax on
profit yeah you pay that on everything
that gets paid on turnover so before we
even get started if you're collecting
500 000 you're going to pay 20 of that
to that after that you pay corporation
tax on any profits that you make
basically pay tax Every Which possible
way would be a spend by
breathe you pay tax what I'm not saying
it's a bad plan all I'm saying is your
projections are going to wail let's have
a look at your actual plan then so
objectives year one service
accommodation brand recognized
corporately by three firms I don't know
what that means so I want to build it
and I want to actually be like a first
line of contact for companies who use
for their staff so they're like oh look
we've got people coming and then I'll be
like yep I'll sort these out this is
where they can stay it doesn't say that
though it just says I want to be a brand
recognized corporately by three firms
established brand to be booked as a
guest speaker four times per year that's
actually a deal sourcing business that's
for your service accommodation that's
for your personal brand
but it's for me they're all together
although they're under different
business names it's all working together
so me building that brand is to build
recognition for the company what is that
I'm offering it's like when you know
these bigger Brands like another hotels
and stuff that you know Holiday Inn and
all these things people know them
because of how it is that they're
represented but people know the Brand's
a holiday and people know the brands
because you know you stay at the hotels
you don't know the brands because
their director is a guest speaker four
times a year
are we over complicating you're having
three businesses is it really just two
businesses and you're gonna Market yeah
for them do you know what I mean yeah
so explain your vision to everything
because I'm not clear on your vision so
you've put USP to build relationships
and familiarity with clients
professional and corporate encourage
repeat bookings
that's not a USB is that I think you
might have over complicated it a little
bit with the three companies ideally you
want to be a bit simpler yeah because
there's so much jargon in there
like we're just we're looking at well I
don't know what you're talking about
yeah and you want whoever was reading it
to be able to understand it without
having to have you there explaining it
as you go through yeah good luck tonight
thank you
[Music]
and it's a bit confusing as well your
business plan there's like three
businesses there's one on a marketing
branding business you don't have a
separate business for sales and
marketing and admin and you have your
business and then you do your marketing
and you do your sales for that business
so there's the marketing business what
was it called again
that was just my name what was it called
CK Cheryl Caprice and is that going to
actually make any money in and of itself
so
I mean if it all goes under one it will
that's the idea how will that business
make money so the idea is just through
you know content creation who's going to
pay you for that business there isn't
you put it in your plan I mean simply
asking you a question about you know how
he's going to make money yeah so it's
going to be the inspirational kind of
motivational side it's a part of my
journey into getting into the property
is I've had to go through things and
speaking to other and networking there's
a lot of people going through the same
things so who will be your customer so
the customer it will be the people who I
meet at networking who want to kind of
over come over that hurdle because they
want to take that step but what they're
paying you for so it's going to be like
motivational inspirational kind of
packages so I still have to refine it
and I've put in the business plan
because as I'm going through my journey
and I record it and notice it doesn't
make any sense I don't know what you're
talking about
uh he was confused as me or what's your
I was yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
are we good you doing really good
to let you know that your business plans
the business plan is also important to
be able to spot holes in other people's
business plans
[Laughter]
yeah there's no time for sentiment here
isn't it we're streets are savagery yeah
yeah
you pick up the same holes that Russell
picks up but
good luck and I'll see you guys in the
boardroom tomorrow thank you mate thank
you Samuel see you soon bye
well no time for emotion now then it's
not over
[Laughter]
okay well let's let's do it bring it on
yeah
it's good
I mean it works in my benefit
oh that was okay you know yeah it's good
but like you know I know what mine looks
like just from how mine is laid out I
put a lot of thought into the end user
and what experience I wanted them to
have when they picked up the pack
and one of the priorities I wanted them
to experience is when they pick up the
pack is a bit kind of like social media
it's bam it's bam spam because
sometimes when there's a lot of text you
get confused and what happens when you
confuse them you lose them so
so with Adam's plan when I first opened
it there was a lot of text so um you
know eventually I just ended up kind of
skimming through to try and find the
thing that was going to make me say okay
this is what's happening so yes I know
for him it was good but overall I wasn't
clear at the end myself in what exactly
he was going to do I just know what he
wants to do in general
what do you think about Charles Bond
so I've got shirelle's business plan in
front of me her strategy
from what I'm getting from it is uh rent
to essays
it is a different strategy to what I'm
going for
she's very very good at putting numbers
in charts and and projections
still feel strong I don't feel like I've
put maybe as much
data in my business plan but the
business plan that I've gone with I
think is so strong and so it's about as
safe as an investment can be I think
Samuel was gonna
potentially pull hers apart I think he's
going to be worried that she's spending
that 20 grand not recycling it like me
she's going to be physically spending me
I mean one of the costs he's got on
there as an accountant
I'm going to be using his money to pay
for my account and I've already got
accountants
for me I mean what stuck out was the
deal sourcing aspect as well I think you
know you can start being a deal source
so with pretty much nothing behind you
that element of it surprised me that she
wanted to do that with regards to the
rent to rent aspect I think it's a great
strategy but I think there's too many
risks for me if I was going to put a lot
of money into it like in one lump in a
cash injection rather than just control
property I'd rather own them yeah it
just feels a bit Airy you know rent to
rent a lot you know you're talking a lot
of money to put into rentals which
potentially could fund themselves so if
you've got two rental rents you could
use the profits to grow more it could
just organically kind of grow do you
know what I'm saying yeah and then the
whole video and inspiring and I get that
as a person maybe because that's my
personal mission I want to become
successful because I I really want to be
able to pull other people up I get that
but it's just I don't understand what
you're talking about I said you made it
very clear I said I want the winner of
the eviction 2022 to be somebody that
goes on to be very successful and I want
to see what you're going to do what your
plans are and you didn't give me
anything you just said rent to rent and
then a bunch of fluff about motivational
stuff which didn't make any sense
[Music]
so doing this challenge by ourselves but
we're still staying in the house
together it's going to be a bit weird
right like we're walking past and then
it's going to be like that look at my
laptop or are we going to help each
other like I don't know how it's going
to be like but I think we're going to so
be focused on what it is that we want
for ourselves and time's gonna go quick
so it's going to be interesting
is it good
beautiful
the batter isn't it I don't see any
butter
leave us in the frischer
do you um you miss anyone in particular
are you bond with anyone particularly
Isabella you know really yeah
who did you Bond very fast
were you there and you told the story
about when you wrote his BMW off
I'll probably shouldn't say
it's a bit sweet one because we've spent
the last challenge working together
and that was so good
but now to know that we're technically
on opposing teams we've got our eyes on
the prize so
we do what we need to do it's not
personal exactly that that's what I was
gonna say yeah
you gotta fight the corner no of course
we've already spoken about him you know
outside of the ballroom you know we know
we're friends you know we know we'd work
together and
[Music]
um so be good yeah I'm looking forward
to it
so my name is Evans Willy I'm last
year's winner of the eviction and I'm
here today to be on the other side of
the camera and help you know help the
team Inspire them find out why they're
here what's the reason why they should
win I think they're both incredible I
think they both bring different things
to the party and I think it's tough I
think it's honestly down to who is going
to put the best work in and who's going
to fight their Corner the most
how's it going strong
big Adam how's it going man ah it's good
it's good it's good in it I'm excited
yeah got this far yeah I'm buzzing do
you think you would have got this far
when you started when I came into it I
definitely looked around and I saw some
really really good people you know
really strong contenders I'd say I
didn't come in the strongest but coming
out the back of it I feel you know
really really strong What would life
look like if you want why do you have to
be the winner genuinely the processes
I've learned here I'm going to go on to
implement them so I want to pay it
forward and I think being the winner it
will just be further Testament to the
journey that I've been on so far the
winner of the eviction is going to win
20 000 pounds why would you deserve to
win that over you know Cheryl for
example I think for me
I'm the main Breadwinner of the family
I'm the only one that earns in the
family for so many years I've worked so
hard and I've not really managed to get
to where I want to get to yeah so by by
me doing this and and implementing the
strategies that Samuel's been teaching
me I feel like I can finally level up to
the next level and get my family to
where I want to get them what would you
do if you did not win what would what
would your life look like if you didn't
win if I didn't win do you know what the
business plan is there and the actions
are still going to be carried out this
process has got me to the point where if
I don't win it's not going to stop it's
just going to help catapult me that bit
quicker now if the coin flipped and you
didn't win what would your well your
life look like how you know how would
you take it I would Shake It Off I I
I'll keep tracking man I'm gonna get to
where I've got to get to you know I'm
hungry for it and I've also got bigger
dreams you know above that so and I'm
going for it poor man talk to me about
those big good rims I remember one of my
first memories when I was a kid that my
mum ran away with me because my dad was
abusive the place that she ran to is
like women screaming and I can remember
it quite Vivid I was only like four
years old I'd love to be able to build
proper housing for women that's got
crashes you know it's got psychological
help and and psychiatrists that can help
them get through their addictions and
and things like that that's that's my
huge goal like that's why I'd really
love to get to I just want to help
so my mother-in-law is a massive uh part
of my life and when she was
um in her last days in her last moments
you know one of the massive messages
that she left was that
she's lived her life her way like in a
sense of don't be sad for her because
she's made her decisions and she's lived
her life and I was sitting there as a
shadow of myself for all these years it
was it was a massive wake-up call
especially coming from someone who I had
so much respect and love for
like when you're alive and there's
something you want to do you have no
choice but to try it it doesn't matter
if you fail or not you have to try it
you have to give it your best and give
it your all
and then you know and then you can move
on to the next thing
I think she will I don't bring different
things to the table I think cherelle has
got a point of reference I think she's
obviously got a massive reason why I
think Adam will do well regardless I
think how you do anything is how you do
everything Adam runs obviously a very
good Italian business so I'm actually
talking to the middle around
why do you think I'm even doing this why
do you think I put on this show and said
that we're going to have a 20 000 man
prize why do you think I'm even doing it
I think you want to you want to
genuinely see someone grow from it I
think you you want to give them that
bump start because that's how it feels
to me this 20 grand would bump start my
journey I'm gonna do it come hella high
water I will do it Wild Horses won't
stop me but the 20 grand would really
help
[Music]
well I'm gonna have to ultimately make a
decision
look at that man
my little my little sofa money under the
sofa
ultimately I'm only going to be able to
let one person go through one person is
going to get 20 grand you're both great
contestants I think you're both going to
do really really well in the business
however there's only one winner so I'm
going to give you each a little
opportunity to say why it should be you
and then I'm going to make my decision
so shirelle why should you get the 20
grand
[Music]
hi
hi baby
hello hello
this is my middle son
my daughter
you say hi
say hi
it's been a change because she was the
Pinnacle of the family so it shows the
the glue should I say so not having a
show in the household for the last two
and a half weeks has been a completely
different Dynamic most definitely what
I'm very supportive on anything sure I
want to do plus because I know the
individuals in which my wife is going to
the top it's Limitless you know there's
a saying that worker exists who can
outdo anyone with natural talent and I
strongly believe that so A lot of people
are gifted in this world a lot of people
are lucky some people are born with a
silver spoon but you can lose it all
overnight without applying yourself and
that's a quality that's real always has
it's not necessarily about the 20 000
it's about what the 2500 could turn into
and we'll probably bless the be in a
situation where the 20 000 isn't
everything to us in that respect very
grateful for the start like I said to
you before I want to be able to invest
it and turn it into more so we can get
into a position to do other things so I
feel like this would be an opportunity
for me although I'll talk to you about
everything it'll be an opportunity for
me to kind of really prove my skills and
what I can do and I think that's the
dream is that to be in a position
potentially where if we wanted to just
get up and go we could we could afford
to have tutors for the kids so they
could still be educated and we could
plant ourselves anywhere in the world
so sure I didn't win I know that sure
will still look at as if she's one
coming this far into the final you're
already a winner and it opens doors you
know you see it on things like game
shows and reality TV shows it's not
always the person that wins that
actually goes and does the greater
things it's all down to that individual
nevertheless and you can't take that
away winning doesn't Define that it's
what you do after this chapter and
there's no concerns there whatsoever so
100 she's won it anyway it doesn't
matter what the result is
so the reason why I should get the 20
grand is because although my business
plan it it doesn't have the full context
of what it is that I'm saying I can go
back and I can revise that and I'm
actually going to put into action so
it's going to raise the brand that I
want to do for my business and it's just
gonna it's just gonna facilitate me
actually bringing this into action and
you talk a lot about getting your
message out there what is your message
my message is that you know you just got
to keep going because it's so easy to
see a barrier and just stop to get
caught down in the nine to five or if
you're at home and then mum you're just
there and our mind is like our most
important it's our most important organ
that we have so if we can nurture that
and look after it the world would just
be a better place and I know it sounds
like you know very fairy turlish but I
have that belief and I will have that
dream and I will keep you know having
these goals to reach it it's not just a
dream why do you think you should win
over Adam
my work ethic is just absolutely at the
top and I've said it before like I may
not be the most talented the most Smart
in the room but my work ethic and my
desire is what's going to push me it's
not going to stop so like my passion my
work ethic my work rate you know that's
why I think I should get it yeah okay
Adam
why do you think you should
win the 20 grand cash and be eviction
2022 winner
um
um
thank you
sorry
are you Tom sorry
I've worked my ass off all my life and
uh
I'm still stuck on a council estate you
know there's a murder on my street about
a year ago and uh
I just want better for my girls
sorry can I have a break second
hello
hi darling hello you okay babies
it's been
very stressful hasn't it yeah it's taken
a lot from me I think you've struggled a
little bit as well
me being away and yeah it has just been
really hard just because we're not we're
quite a needy couple
so we're not really used to being apart
your confidence has grown massively
hasn't it well that's what I was telling
Samuel this morning in the ballroom like
my family are quite loud and when they
come over he just observes he just
watches us yeah I'm not one for
competing am I no you don't compete for
air time do you
yeah we booked a trip to Turkey our
first holiday in four and a half years
and then one day you just turned around
and said that you applied for the
eviction it's we will be traveling
without him and he will be joining us
four days after but as as weird and as
strange as it's going to be it's very
worthy yeah just the growth and the
journey for you has been amazing hasn't
it yeah
yeah it's been crazy to get to the end
of the eviction it's amazing yeah it is
I think never having an injection of
money you know and always having to work
my ass off for everything that I've ever
got never been given any help have I but
no Adam doesn't have a family so
everything that we have is just through
him and his determination his hard work
and and I would like it to see it pay
off as well I have dedicated you've been
yeah you know it would be nice I just
want to get out of here I don't know I
just want to take you to a better place
don't get tearful because I'll cry
foreign
[Music]
is really quite rough for me to bring my
family up like that it feels like I'm a
failure I'm just so sick of it and I
just want to make my family so proud and
for the skills that I've gained over the
years you know working really hard is
all very well and good but
unless you've got the knowledge that you
you just can't grow
come hell or high water whether I get
this 20 grand or not I'm not staying
there and nothing will stop me to get
where I need to get to
so what do you think so shirelle's
business plan was overly complicated
there was lots of jargon in there and it
took me I had to have her explain it to
me to understand it she wants to get 50
service accommodation units 10 a year
over the next five years what does she
actually want the 20 grand for so
primarily that which is to get her first
five units does she really need the 20
grand to do that though or because you
get a hands on the 20 grand elsewhere or
does she have 20 grand
she definitely needs Capital to get the
business started yeah Evans what do you
think of shirelle after speaking to all
the other day I think she's got a very
strong reason why she's a mom she's got
three kids she's left them at home to be
here so she's very hungry and she wants
to give back so yeah I really like her
so if you or me Evans
who would you give the 20 000 pounds to
the good stuff I think based on the
business plan I'll probably give it to
Sharelle the reason why because Adam
told me he wants to do bras in reading
and I'm like if you have 20 going in
Reading you still need more money he's
like he's going to raise it I'm like if
you're going to raise the remainder why
can't you know raise all of the money so
I think it's funny because that's
basically the conversation I had exactly
the problem with Adam's business plan
number one the biggest problem with it
is it isn't a business plan let me show
you because I'm a numbers guy right so I
like to look at the the figures
projections Etc this is his
that's his numbers page
yeah there's just nothing the rest of it
is just talking about how great service
accommodation is basically it's like a
brochure for Airbnb but he's had like
three days to do this there's no talk of
how much profit he's going to make how
many assets they're going to have he's
just weak isn't it oh it's terrible it's
just weak and then shirelle's business
plan I don't think she needs the money
from you I think she could just do it
slightly slower do one rent to rent
and then use the money from that to do
the next one and so on and so forth she
could just sell fund it couldn't she
from her projects yeah she's already got
one minute to rent well it was
shirelle's business plan there's no
investments in there it's literally just
growing that rent to rent business
bigger and bigger and bigger whereas
actually what I would recommend doing
you suit more like Adams where you're
buying stuff
but then Adams is missing the first
stage it's kind of like you if you
combine the two you'd have a really good
plan my worry of Adam's plan though is
it isn't a business plan it's basically
just borrow money and buy property I
don't see how it's a business well yeah
I mean obviously you know it's why we
never never written a business plan
before it's the first time doing that I
was in issues you know just just over a
year ago and I know what it's like but
he lives in the council list that I
think it can really be a big big
breakthrough for him when you put your
business plan together you add steps
leading up to this I do agree but I
think for the business plan to work so
the person has to work and I think Adam
has proved that he can work so maybe
with a little bit I'll be a help on his
business plan I think he's gonna thrive
all said and done
who should I give the 20 grand to
[Applause]
goodness FaceTime girls hey girlies you
all right you look great are we miss you
I told you you've got to just enjoy it
you've got make the most of it
oh don't be silly
I'll be out there soon enough I'm still
feeling like my my plan is solid
she's definitely a really professional
business plan together she's put a lot
of figures in and you know a lot of
charts and
projections but she wants to do rental
essays and a deal selling company and
I've seen like projection for year five
and to be honest this is around the 200
Grand Mark with my projection if I can
complete 10 projects which is more than
doable in five years we'd have probably
over a million pounds just in equity in
our properties and the fact that I can
keep recycling the money I'm not
actually physically spending it
yeah yeah and if your business plan is
strong enough which it is then it really
doesn't matter about the payout it
speaks for itself doesn't it really
[Music]
am I going to win the eviction for me I
feel like it's inevitable because the
reason why I'm here is to do my best to
live my best and go above and beyond I'm
determined to be the best of me I'm
determined to maximize on the skills I'm
determined to take that training and
implement it and you know the magic is
going to happen
Samuel says you know get comfortable
feeling uncomfortable and that's exactly
what I've been doing so I'll do whatever
it takes to make sure I win you can't
come in with an attitude that you're not
going to win I'm definitely wanting to
win
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to make a decision I like both of
you but I have to make a decision Adam
you're a really nice guy it's too nice
and I think you're going to be
successful I will this was about your
business plan and your business plan
sucked shirelle your business done was
better it was a bit confusing
I love where you're coming from from a
position of helping other people I'm
about that I Vibe with you very really
well
I've made my decision
[Music]
I've made my decision and my decision is
that I think that shirelle
where you are right now
and you want to help other people and
Inspire the people I think you can
already do that and I think I can work
with you and I'd love to work with you
guys to do that but Adam
you are going to be receiving the 20 000
pounds cash
[Music]
yeah I'm good
oh God
shirelle you're amazing and we're going
to work together closely okay
okay
I'm good
I'm good
I lost the eviction
and that's it
[Music]
you go through something like this no
matter what if you don't win you're
gonna feel
what you're gonna feel isn't it
[Music]
uh mixed bag of feelings for me
um
I mean yeah there's a massive element
shock it's um
it's not every day that someone gifts
you 20 000 pounds
it's really really hard
I am
felt on all the challenges you know
I took the information and I put into
action I surprised myself and it just
feels like that wasn't enough
that's not easy to do
I just hope that shirelle knows how
powerful she is I know she's gonna
succeed no matter what
look how I feel right now is now
greatness is still coming for me it's
inside me and that will never change and
that's one thing I've been blessed with
which is why I want to share that with
everyone but the reality is you do go
through things and you do
you know you sometimes you have to sit
with the pain so I'm gonna sit with it
and I'm going to absorb it and then I'm
just going to come back better and
that's it you know
foreign
[Music]
yeah I'm doing very well
we won
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I guess like I can't believe it you know
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
people that were in the eviction they've
got a fire in their belly they were
desperate to get to the finish line and
the fact that I've got to the Finish
Line I mean it's just a bit of a pinch
me moment
[Music]
finally managed to get with my family
gals
it's amazing here
good
foreign
[Music]